The Greenbrier is a Forbes four star, AAA
Five diamond Award winning luxury resort in
West Virgina. It's also the site of a massive
underground bunker meant to serve as an emergency
shelter for the US congress during the cold
war....
What the FAK... The facts and knowledge on
real post-apocalyptic shelters
Vivos is a privately funded network of underground
shelters with a location in Indiana and another
in Kansas. The Indiana location costs $50,000
per adult and $35,000 per child, it accommodates
80 people for a minimum of one year without
having to surface, and can withstand a 20
megaton blast. The Kansas survival shelter
is a massive 2 million square foot area that
is being outfitted now. It'll be able to accommodate
5000 people for a minimum of one year. Located
130 feet below the surface of a mountain and
carved out of solid limestone
They
plan to preserve one out of every million
human on earth's, artifacts, DNA and reproductive
cells, as well as books, data, and more.
The Adirondack Missile Silo is an old military
Atlas F missile Silo converted into a luxury
underground shelter. Located in Upstate New
York, there is a 2000 square foot log home
on the surface of the structure. The underground
shelter is a 2300 square foot 2 story luxury
home. The silo tube is 52' in diameter and
185 feet deep. The security doors are able
to withstand a 2000 lb blast. They plan to
continue to renovate and make it into a larger
survival condo that is able to accommodate
multiple people. But it's for sale as is right
now for 3 million dollars.
The luxury survival condo is also built out
of an Atlas F missile base that has undergone
massive cleanup and restoration. It accommodates
between 36 and 70 people for 5 years completely
off the grid with 54,000 square feet of underground
protected space. Each buyer has the ability
to own a half floor unit designed for 3-5
people or a full floor unit designed for 6-10
people, equipped with a five year supply of
high quality freeze dried food. The facility
has a water filtration and reservoir system
that insures the water supply is safe as well
as hydroponic gardens and aquaculture to provide
residents with fresh vegetables and fish for
food.
For just $10,000 per person Atlas survival
shelters will build and install a galvanized
corrugated pipe shelter in an undisclosed
location of your choice. They're buried up
to 42' deep and have a lifespan of 200 years.
Each unit comes standard with removable floor
boards for under floor storage, bunk beds,
air filtration systems, blast valves, and
an emergency escape hatch hidden underground.
You can even get one of these boulders to
conceal your escape hatch.
The underground city, located in China, is
a bomb shelter built in the 1970's in anticipation
of a nuclear war with the Soviet Union. Built
by 300,000 local citizens including children,
it was mostly dug by hand. The tunnels cover
33 square miles and is 26-59 feet under the
surface with 90 entrances hidden in shops
along the main streets. It opened in 2000
as a tourist attraction and is kept up by
the city, but has been closed for renovation
for a while.
I'm gonna leave you with this blast door.
Where is it, how heavy is it and how large
of an explosion can it handle?
Before we go here's last video's winner. Be
sure to subscribe for more Vsauce2 and as
always thanks for watching.